je suis pas un expert mais ça c'est un
truc genre vraiment contraire à la loi
non ils ont un système judiciaire genre
différent ici c'est désert aller au
travail
la rive les autres ont pensé qu'il
pourrait peut-être nous aider les autres
lawrence
je ne vais pas rester à ne rien faire
car c'est notre survie qui est en jeu
d'accord ça l'italie bravo vous êtes un
homme précieux en cas de crise
attila ça aide les bus
aujourd hui ses coffres sont bien plus
grand qu'on pense 8 d'abord nous sommes
venus aussi tu sais qui encore tu seras
peut perdre et sans nous dit sinon le
capucin plomb en gros tout le monde est
là ah bah non mais je vois vraiment pas
l'intérêt d'avoir fait venir ce